As new details emerge
about what happened to the world's greatest golfer.
At the hospital,
he had no recollection of the crash itself.
But there was an issue about if he was under the influence,
some type of prescribed medication, for example,
or if they did any blood work at the hospital
that would require a search warrant
to be able to see that information.
E.T. has been with Tiger for his epic highs,
his fall from grace, and stunning comeback in 2019.
I love playing golf,
but now, I'm starting to love just being around people.
We first sat down with Woods in 1996.
So, what are your plans for the 21st birthday?
Ha, no comment.
I've hit the greens with Tiger several times.
We've discussed his wedding to then wife, Elin Nordegren.
The whole idea is for us to be private.
And his desire to have kids.
It's just one of those things that I've never experienced,
but I certainly would like to one day.
Tiger's 12 year old son Charlie
is like his golf twin.
And as for another comeback...
I've always been taught by my parents
never to give any thought to anyone's expectations
but yourselves.
In the wake of the horrific crash
and Tiger's extensive surgeries,
fellow golfer, Rory McIlroy, put it all into perspective.
He's not Superman.
He's a human being at the end of the day.
And you know, he's already been through so much.
At their stage,
I think everyone should just be grateful
that he's here, that he's alive,
that his kids haven't lost their dad.
Golf is not even on the map at this point.
(salsa outro music)